how can you not learn incredible things
with the people that are here
I'm Andrew MA it's my 51st birthday I'm
a broadcaster and writer and on the
quiet I'm an optimist my name is
Jennifer Jack wet I'm a postdoc at the
University of British Columbia and I
studied conservation and cooperation my
name is Alex Kotowski
I'm a researcher and academic and a
journalist focusing on the social
histories of new technologies
specifically looking at how the web has
transformed our world I'm Poe Davies and
my interests are cosmology astrobiology
and cancer research mic man Penn State
University climate science and science
communication my name is Marcus de Soto
I'm a professor of mathematics and also
the professor for the public
understanding of science at the
University of Oxford
Paul Sereno I'm an artist a scientist
and my work I described as adventure
with the purpose
Seifer who is an incredible pot pourri
of just everybody out of the Sun with
every kind of new angle as scientists
were often used to mostly interacting
with our our colleagues others in our
field at an event like this we have an
opportunity to talk to people working on
completely different kinds of problems
who bring in completely different
perspectives and really can provide us
some some novel insights into our own
work I've reached that stage in my life
where I'm trying to synthesize my many
different interests which range from the
origin of the universe to the origin of
life to the nature of cancer and you
might think these subjects are so
disparate they have no links but I'm
finding links all the time and cypher is
a great place to learn how clever people
in different disciplines can come
together in creative ways and find
bridges between their different subjects
so people say that with sheep
personalized genomic information our
genomes in front of us we will use this
in a serious way to change our
lifestyles and what I've learned today
that we won't we're going to use that
information to find out strange quirky
facts about ourselves or factoids
because an awful lot of people are going
to become snake oil salesmen and it's
just going to be kind of entertainment
and trivial fun which was pretty much
what we did with the internet I think
I've learned most the potency of
technology because I live in a world
that you can almost still just imagine
these things are happening rather than
confront them face to face and now
seeing the presentations here you
realize it really is happening people
really are building robotic suits to to
convey information from the brain into
movement and that is something that
prior to coming here I really only had
to had to imagine and not actually come
face to face with unlearned I don't know
I haven't really unlearned anything it's
all confirmed my own biases it was
absolutely clear to me that I didn't
understand physics and that in the next
twenty or thirty years that may be left
to me physics is about the last thing
that I'm going to spend any time trying
to understand and I have unlearned that
I think that I've unlearnt that you
should call particular subjects by
particular names that you know we
shouldn't talk about mathematics physics
chemistry what we need to unlearn is to
just to call it all of science and stop
having these barriers between different
subjects I you know I I helped unlearn
actually the fear that a lot of us have
of just walking up to strangers and
saying hey can I sit down at your table
and what are you doing what do I do and
just that fear which we we're normally
we take everywhere we go especially the
scientific meetings we only want to talk
to pee
who are who we recognize you have to
shed that here it's I Fuu what happens
next
is the wine flows and the
interconnections that don't happen in
formal sessions happen and wonderful
bits of networking go on and
extraordinary ideas blossom and then
because the wine flows tomorrow morning
we forget it all next we go away we make
the world a better place with all this
knowledge with all these ideas with all
these contacts and these connections all
these serendipitous meetings is in
person face to face you know human
interactions we just go off and we make
better things really don't we
you